after a two-year investigation
journalist Jake Tapper is out with a new
article about a possible case of
wrongful conviction this is not Justice
the story of CJ rice is a November cover
story for the Atlantic Charles Rice
known as CJ was convicted as a teenager
of attempted murder and sentenced to 30
to 60 years in prison tapper's father Dr
Ted Tapper was Rice's pediatrician at
the time and he believes that Rice could
not physically have even carried out
this crime the father and son will join
us very shortly but first let's take a
look at CJ's case and tapper's Reporting
on it
welcome back to State of the Union I'm
Jake Tapper the CNN anchor Jake Tapper
has spent his career covering the
world's biggest stories so Mississippi
is one of the states that has a a
trigger law now Tapper is taking on a
more personal story one set in his
native Philadelphia it involves a
patient of his father's pediatrician Ted
Tapper this is the case of CJ rice who's
been locked up for more than a decade
for a crime Dr Tapper believes he did
not commit in an Atlantic article that
came out today Tapper outlines Rice's
case at 17 years old back in 2011 rice
was shot while riding his bike in
Philadelphia rice believes it was a
result of mistaken identity rice went to
Dr Tapper for follow-up care in
September 2011.
he had received more than two dozen
Staples fractured his pelvis and lost
muscle strength Dr Tapper says rice
could barely walk and was in a lot of
pain less than a week later the teenager
was arrested for a shooting in South
Philadelphia that injured four people
including a six-year-old girl rice and a
friend were charged in what police saw
as a possible retaliation crime they
were both tried Rice's friend was
acquitted but he was convicted of
attempted murder according to tapper's
reporting in the Atlantic there was
never any physical evidence connecting
rights to the crime eyewitness testimony
was questionable at best and there were
serious issues with his legal
representation Dr tappers also raised
questions about Rice's physical ability
to carry out the shooting and flee the
scene while still recovering from his
injuries
all of this has caused a tappers to look
into the case and now they're speaking
out